this video is made possible by
brilliance you're gonna learn more about
brilliant later in today's video but if
you'd like to learn more about them
right now
and why wouldn't you go to brilliant org
forward slash bar graphics link in the
description below and let's get into it
[Music]
the Sun was setting on the Norwegian
port of Bergen it was early July 13:49
and off in the distance a lone ship was
crossing the line of the horizon the
ship Bob's calmly port to starboard
coming closer interview the inhabitants
of Mergen noticed its tattered sails and
lack of movement on board as gently as
it had appeared the ship entered the
harbor and ran aground every sailor on
board the ship was dead the people of
Bergen were fully aware of the events
unfolding across the rest of Europe over
the previous two years
a mysterious malevolent life consuming
force had spread death and decay all
over the continents until their day
Bergen had been spared Norse mythology
used to tell stories of now far a ship
made entirely of the nails and toe nails
of the dead now how far would appear at
the onset of ragnarök that twilight of
the gods in the end of times the ship of
the deadwood ferry the forces of chaos
to bring destruction upon the realms of
the gods and of humankind's like Naga
fur the ghost ship of Bergen had
appeared from nowhere carrying on board
and agents of destruction and chaos the
scourge of humanity the Black Death
[Music]
so how can we define the black death
today we could say it was the most
successful human conqueror in the
history of mankind if success is
measured by how many trees are cut down
to feed the funeral pars we could say it
was the greatest strategist if greatness
is measured by how little soil remains
to bury the dead what we eventually
defined as the black death was a mid
14th century pandemic of bubonic plague
that came knocking at the gates of Asia
Europe and Africa wrapping with the soft
paws of a sickly rat a guest uninvited
with cruel intent but if you look at the
way the black death spread attacked and
preyed on humans if you consider the
effectiveness with which it encircled
and annihilated entire nations well
you'll be forgiven for thinking that an
even more sinister unnatural power was
at play hell-bent on bringing about the
end of times but this wasn't the first
time humanity had withstood an invasion
by this malevolent angel it had spread
its wings back in the 6th century known
then as the Justinian plague but too
much time had passed too many memories
had been lost when the pandemic returned
humankind was completely unprepared the
Black Death had laid dormant for eight
centuries trapped in a purgatory of
meager rodent prey almost like a
lifeless object it awaited its time of
reprisal against its human enemy we
could not tell why it hated us but we
did find out how much it could hate us
[Music]
[Applause]
it's still unclear where the Black Death
first came from possibly China or maybe
in the steppe region where a plague
reservoir stretches from the northwest
and shores of the Caspian Sea into
southern Russia a plague reservoir looks
like a vast area of wilderness almost
entirely devoid of human life it may
have been there amongst the population
of marmots rats and other rodents that
it first appeared invisible to the naked
eye the unaware mammals all carried the
minions of Black Death the bacterium
which later generations would classify
as yesenia pestis this is the pathogen
at the root of both the bubonic and the
pneumonic plagues and it was believed to
have been endemic to Central Asia we
don't know the exact time in which the
disease started to spread from rodents
to humans
but we know of an early outbreak in 1331
which erupted in China during the rule
of the Wan dynasty this dynasty had been
founded by Kublai Khan the grandson of
Genghis Khan
the Mongols had been an irresistible
force for more than a century but they
had finally met their match three years
later the Black Death it kills more than
90% of the population of he by province
near the capital of daddu or modern-day
Beijing the death toll surpassed five
million people these were the effects of
the conquering disease in just one
province as of 1200 China had a total
population of more than 120 million
people but a census in 1393 found only
65 million Chinese accounted for almost
half of the population of a great Empire
lay debt as the gironde dynasty was
replaced by the Ming's many hundreds of
thousands even millions died in battle
or starved but many many more millions
had fallen prey to the Black Death after
the first outbreaks the rats and their
fleas ridden with yesenia pestis started
their journey westward as stowaways on
the caravans traveling along the Silk
Road at the end of a long day's travel
the merchants would stop at the numerous
caravans arees or resting places dotting
the Silk Road these made perfect
occasions for the possessed fleas to
infect rats animals and other travelers
caravans upon caravans criss crossing
the plains of Central Asia unwittingly
obeyed the bidding of the Black Death
spreading the plague
all of Asia and the Middle East by 1335
the Black Death had infected Persia
during that year the local Mongol ruler
Abu side died of bubonic plague an
estimated one-third of all Persians died
in the ensuing epidemic an event that
marked the beginning of the end of
Mongol rule in the region more Central
Asian cities and communities fell one by
one under the shadow of this Angel of
Death talus mark hands even Sarai this
was the capital of another Mongol States
the carnage of the golden horde it is as
though the Black Death had a personal
grudge against the Mongols maybe it
simply exploited their legendary
mobility to reach the four corners of
the world and acting at all after each
passage the plague did not discriminate
amongst its victims
any king queen or Kahn could become easy
prey after every sweep of the plague
each population center would have lost
at least 40% of its citizens
sometimes the death tolls climbed as
high as 70 percent' understandably the
inhabitants of stricken cities fled in
panic but this only contributed to
further outbreaks of the disease soon
the Black Death had reached the Middle
East where some scholars had already
taken notice of the catastrophe that had
nearly obliterated Asia every now waria
Syrian riot errands later victim of the
plague recorded that the Black Death
came out of the lands of darkness which
may implicate Central Asia or possibly a
much darker and more remote lands beyond
the surf the Egyptian scholar Alma's
Ricci noticed all of Asia was
depopulated as far as the Korean
Peninsula his own country was no luckier
Cairo by then the most populous city in
Africa lost 52% of its inhabitants
almost 14,000 died in just two days the
corpses were so many that in a rare
occurrence religious authorities waved
the required prayers for the dead there
were simply too many a member to toe the
greatest traveler and chronicler of the
14th century had noted in his travel
memoir that as of 1345 the number that
died daily in damascus had been 2,000 a
tutor also wrote that these survivors
had been able to defeat the plague
through prayer but Muslim religious
practices may have actually played in
the black deaths favor the Hajj the
annual pilgrimage to Mecca
find a great route for Yersinia pestis
to seek new hosts by 1349 the holy city
of Mecca had been struck by the plague
the Moroccan historian called dune left
behind an account of the apocalyptic
wastelands civilization both in the east
and the west was visited by a
destructive plague which devastated
nations and caused populations to vanish
cities and buildings were laid to waste
roads and way signs were obliterated
settlements and mansions became empty
dynasties and tribes grew week the
entire inhabited world changed until
recently we'd the descendants of the
survivors assumes that the sahara desert
had stopped the outbreaks that the Black
Death had spared sub-saharan Africa
medieval written records for that region
never mentioned the plague and the area
lacks the most macabre mento of the
pandemic the plague pits or mass graves
it's not entirely clear how but the
thralls of the Black Death thanks to the
fleas and rodents somehow crossed the
inhospitable expanse of sand and
infected communities on both coasts of
the continent archaeologists have found
evidence of societal collapse and
abandonment in the towns of Ghana and
Nigeria other cities and settlements in
East Africa were also abandoned during
the mid 14th century from the coast of
the Red Sea down to Tanzania and even
Madagascar proof is scarce as
geneticists were not able to secure DNA
from African victims of that period and
yes the patterns of sudden collapse and
depopulation are too suspicious the
Black Death was definitely bent on total
world domination Asia had fallen the
conquest of the Middle East and Africa
raged on and the next target was Europe
waves of Yersinia pestis could have
infected the Russian principalities at a
very early stage of the Asia campaign
but the plans of the black death had
been momentarily thwarted by its early
foes and victims the Mongols the Mongol
state in Central Asia the carnate of the
Golden Horde had converted to Islam and
the trade with Christians was no longer
tolerated as a result the Caravan routes
from asia to europe had been cut off
meaning that's the contagion of the
plague stopped abruptly on the mongol
border with the Russian principalities
but as I said the Black Death was a
cunning strategist and
find its way to Europe one way or
another and just before we get into how
that happens I do want to take a quick
moment to thank the people who make this
video possible and that would be
brilliance sponsors like brilliant make
these videos possible and they're a
great fit for this channel because you
probably like learning I mean here you
are in the middle of a video about the
Black Death and brilliance is a great
way to take that learning just a bit
further
brilliant believe that learning math
science computer science doesn't have to
be dull
to that end they've put together courses
that are all about storytelling
interactive challenges and solving
problems it's this hands-on approach
that is really an excellent way to learn
and currently they have over 50
interactive courses look you're halfway
through a video about the Black Plague
so you're probably a curious type and
like I said just he's brilliant to take
that understanding a bit further for
example there's this great course on
scientific thinking allowing you to get
a solid foundation in physics while
doing puzzles great way to learn you'll
also understand the physics of things
like mirror reflections laser tag he
doesn't love laser tag and much more so
effective learning is all about problem
solving and brilliant to help you learn
and practice that it's just a great
complement to videos like this I mean
it's all good to learn something here
the brilliant lights take it deeper so
if you want to support fire graphics and
get unlimited access to all of
brilliance in depth maths and science
courses head on over to brilliant dot
org forward slash bio graphics and get
20% off their annual premium
subscription and now let's get back to
the black death
[Music]
before we move on to the conquest of
Europe allow me to take a look at the
effects of the plague on an individual
Yersinia pestis initially liked to
infect rats and other rodents it takes
from 10 to 14 days for plague bacteria
to exterminate a contaminated rat colony
for the following three days the fleas
infesting these rats will lay in wait
fasting until new prey walks nearby this
prey can be another rat but a hungry
flea will not think twice before
attacking a human after an infected flea
bites a human host yesenia pestis will
invade his or her bloodstream one of the
first symptoms of the contagion is the
swelling of a lymph node most often in
the groin thigh armpit or neck the lymph
node will grow in size taking the
appearance of a swollen blackened and
painful saw this gave it its name the
bubonic plague the three days the
infected individual may feel fine while
the disease incubates then these
symptoms will appear growing in severity
very quickly fever headache chills and
widespread weakness after that it's only
a matter of three more days then in more
than 80% of cases the infected
individual will die it takes 14 days for
your senior to exterminate a rat colony
another three days before infected fleas
contaminate the first human six days
later the first human dies that makes a
23 day period from the introduction of
plague amongst rats to the first human
death in a given community a strange
number 23 try and divide 2 by 3 and what
do you get
0.666 the number of the bunch I'm sure
there's no relation but Illuminati
confirms but you know the speed and
perversion with which the Black Death
killed well it did have a demonic
quality in some cases plague bacteria
became concentrated in the lungs and
cost symptoms similar to pneumonia this
was a pneumonic plague ins of course it
was even more violent than the bubonic
version people with pneumonic plague
could die as early as two hours after
catching the disease what's worse
pneumonic plague sufferers can easily
infect healthy individuals as they are
beset with violent bloody fits of
coughing the droplets they expel can
easily infiltrate other people's Airways
resulting in the cycle of contagion
surprisingly however the VAR
majority of black death victims were not
caused by human on human contagions
infections were almost exclusively due
to bites from fleas that had previously
sucked blood off a rat
the tiny parasites could attack directly
after feasting on rats blood or
sometimes they traveled unnoticed aboard
another animal or human host
the black death had to rely heavily on
rats for its invasion plans and this had
an effect on both the geographic spread
of the invasion as well as its timeline
rats had thrived on ships especially
merchant ships which at the time were
able to travel 40 kilometers or 25 miles
every day this is why the Black Death
in Europe appeared to conquer in leaps
and bounds rather than following a
linear path as it was in Asia rat fleas
are parasites that are most active in
the warmer seasons which explains why
the Springs and summers of the mid 14th
century it became unusually lethal
winter is coming must have sounded like
a promise back then as the plague lost
most of its contagion power in colder
months doctors at the time could do
little to fight the black death the most
common form of treatment was lansing or
piercing buboes which expelled a reeking
black liquid other methods involved
leaching or bleeding the ill or washing
their bodies with vinegar a much later
book head with the fourths plague
medicines of 1480 reports and medicine
commonly used take an egg that is newly
laid and make a hole in either ends and
blow out all that is within and lay it
to the fire and let it roast slit may be
ground to powder but do not burn it then
take a quantity of good treacle and mix
it with chives and good ale and then
make the sick drink it for three
evenings and three mornings this was
obviously totally futile but maybe at
least the Ale was good
[Music]
in 1344 the golden horde decided to lay
siege the port city of cava on the
Crimean Peninsula since the late 1200 s
Cavor been under the rule of Genoa one
of the four Italian sea Republic's the
Genoese resisted the Mongols for three
years but in 1347 reinforcements from
the Golden Horde arrived and they
brought with them something undesired
the plague an Italian lawyer Gabrielle
de masas describes the last stages of
the siege the whole army was affected by
a disease which over and the Mongols and
killed thousands upon thousands every
day the Mongol leader ordered corpses to
be placed in catapults and lobbed into
the city in hopes that the intolerable
stench would kill everyone inside
catapulting your own dead soldiers
inside the city walls well there's a
tactic that would certainly pleased
general black death but Gabrielle's is
the only account of such an event so it
may simply be an exaggeration
nonetheless the infection soon spread
within the city walls and from there
pushed out by the double threat of the
Mongols and the plague the Genoese
merchants escaped by ship the war waged
by the Black Death in Asia had been on
lands relying on caravans and the fast
Mongol cavalry the invasion of Europe
though it would be a more nautical one
in October of 1347 one of the Genoese
ships landed in the Sicilian port of
Messina it was clear to the port
officials that something was wrong most
of the crew were dead and the rest they
spoke about a mysterious disease that
had ravaged him the survivors were
prevented from leaving the ships and
after a few days they were all dead
a contemporary account reads the sailors
brought in their bones the disease so
violence that whoever spoke a word to
them was infected and could in no way
save himself from death there then
appears on a sigh or an arm a pustule
like a lentil from this the infection
penetrated the body and violence bloody
vomiting began it lasted for a period of
three days and there was no way of
preventing its ending in death so
whoever spoke a word to the sick was
infected no one had thought about the
rats
loyal to their Black Death Master that
scurried over the ropes connecting the
ship to the docks
these tightrope walkers were the
executioner's of yore
the outbreak at Messina is often cited
as the first landing of the Black Death
in Europe but the Genoese sailors from
kapha made several other stops both
before and after Messina everytime
spreading the plague in so-called
metastatic leaps the Black Death had
arrived in Constantinople in May of 1347
where it had launched from the Adriatic
coast
it reached Marseille in September
throughout autumn the Genoese or those
who had been infected by them landed in
all major trading hubs of the
Mediterranean Dubrovnik Venice Pisa
Genoa Valencia all of these ports were
the bridgeheads Firth the invasion force
which then broke through to the mainland
more merchant ships fell to the Black
Death resulting in more metastatic leaps
by March 1348 southern France northern
Spain and almost all of Italy were
living under the shadow of the Conqueror
the wealthy city-state of Florence had
been struck harder than other Italian
towns it's estimated that 70% of its
citizens died within the few early
months of the plague the outbreak
inspired Seminole author Boccaccio two
writers de Cameron this is how he
describes the massacre if first betrayed
itself by the emergence of certain
tumors in the groin or the armpit some
of which grew as large as common apples
others as an egg and he died daily or
nightly in the public streets of many
others who died at home the departure
was hardly observed by their neighbors
until the stench of the bodies carried
the news the black death then crept
northward from the French Mediterranean
bridgeheads the hordes of yesenia
infected rats moved inland and reached
the Atlantic ports it was a ship from
Bordeaux that took the plague to England
the first town to be affected was
Markham Regis where the epidemic broke
out shortly in the 24th London Valley in
August of 1348 by January 13 49 the
population was so depleted especially of
clergymen that the Bishop of bathra this
to his diocese the plague has left many
parish churches without parson or priest
to care for their parishioners
therefore if parishioners are on the
point of death and cannot secure the
services of a priest then they should
make confession to each other if no man
is present and even to a woman the
entire kingdom had been contaminated by
the end of 1349 further north Norway was
the first Scandinavian country to be
invaded also Col Thurston
the autumn of 1348 the outbreak in Oslo
was mercifully stopped by the advent of
winter weather but it broke out again in
the early spring the following year the
Black Death completed its pincer
movement against Norway with a second
landing the ghost ship at Bergen the
plague zone alpha was a ship of wool
merchants from the English port of
King's Lynn taking Oslo was a strategic
master strike for the Black Death the
city was a major trading hub for the
Hanseatic fleet a league of rich and
powerful merchant town stretching from
the North Sea to the Baltic needless to
say the merchant sailing off Oslo
disseminated a cargo they could not
fathom to new destinations Denmark
Sweden northern Germany soon fell as
well the new front opened in the spring
of 1350 and moved southward crushing the
populace with the same plague invasion
that had entered southern Germany from
Austria now the Black Death that spreads
to almost all of Europe it plotted its
next move this was one that would spell
disastrous for conquerors in later
centuries that of course is invading
Russia it had already tried entering
from the east but the Golden Horde had
stopped the caravans along the Silk Road
now though nobody would stop the scourge
of Nations the plague answered the
Principality of Novgorod in late autumn
of 1351 but the onset of the cold
stopped the outbreak but it was only
temporary the progress of the disease
resumed in spring of 1350 to reaching
Moscow the following year the Black
Death reached the border with the Golden
Horse this time from the West bringing
its Odyssey full circle in the same year
the pandemic petered out Iceland and
Finland's were the only countries that
evaded the apocalypse the rest of the
continent was on its knees
the death toll is still debated
according to conservative estimates the
black death had swept away twenty to
thirty percent of Europe's population
recent calculations placed the number
much higher nearer sixty percent that's
fifty million men women and children who
lost their lives because of the bite of
the tiniest and humless parasites that
one could imagine humanity simply did
not have the tools to combat this
invisible foe doctors didn't have a cure
and even preventive measures were
insufficient germ theory were still
centuries away but authorities did
understand that the proximity of
contaminated individuals would spread
the disease several cities implemented
quarantined preventing travelers from
entering within their walls but they
could never realistically hope to
contain though was rats and fleas
creeping in from everywhere simply
undetected so well what did finally stop
the Black Death then well it was a
combination of two elements first the
onset of colder and longer winters
killed off many plague carrying fleas
seconds the disease itself was too
effective to be efficient the plague
killed off its victims to quickly rats
and humans alike this prevented them
from traveling further afield carrying
the bacteria to more and more hosts the
Europe that slowly recovered after the
Year 1353 was a transformed continent
surprisingly some of the societal
changes were for the better the poorer
sections of the population enjoyed a
better diet better working conditions
and a longer life expectancy this was a
consequence of the reduction in work
force it prompted feudal lords to
increase their labourers wages and find
innovative ways to increase the
productivity of their lands the epidemic
also had an impacts on the spread of
culture and education has travelled at
traditional university cities became
dangerous new scholarship centers were
founded allowing for the multiplication
and diversification of academia the
Black Death may eventually died out but
its carriers the ascender pestis
bacteria evolved into a different strain
a strain more selective yet equally
malicious one that would be able to pick
its victims based on their age this
became the second wave in 1361 one that
would target specifically the younger
rungs of society the most innocent and
vulnerable this would become known as
the
second pestilence or the plague of
children but well that's a story for
another day
someone gonna ask if you like to this
incredibly dark video but if you did
find it interesting and informative I
love it if you gave it a thumbs up below
it does help get this video in front of
more people also why not subscribe to
this channel we've got videos four times
per week we've also got a sister channel
which you'll probably like good
Geographics linking to that below also
most important of all please do check
out our fantastic sponsor for this
episode brilliant you will find a link
to them below and as always thank you
for watching